you can't do the same intro twice
what am i doing no imagination alright
so my mortal kombat spoiler free review
you all clocked in some good views on
that
thank you very much this video is for
that small percentage of you
who care to know more that's to say this
is my mortal kombat 2021 movie
spoiler talk that's a spoiler warning i
actually saw a comment in my
spoiler-free video
of someone being like this is the most
positive good time if you're drunk video
i think i've
ever seen but the reason for that is
because all the things where i'm like
well actually the lauren that i had a
problem with like it's all spoiler it's
all tied in with spoilers so this is
that video
hope this video doesn't come off as too
negative remember what i said in my
spoiler free review i like the tone
there's some dumb made up lore
but i'm interested to see more in that
universe if they can get some better
writers
that's the video in a nutshell okay so
talking about the spoilers
mortal kombat starts out and it starts
out on a very strong note because it's
scorpion versus sub-zero i think the
first seven minutes of the movie is
it's online bihan versus hanzo asashi
link way versus shirai ryu
and they fight well it's kind of a
massacre which is a story you know the
link way wipes out the shirai ryu wipes
out scorpion or
hanzo asashi his entire family and clan
i think that's a good note to start out
on but i also when i
see that and i see how this movie had
so much packed into it in terms of
characters where it's like
it had to phrase it it had the
characters but not a lot of the
backstory of the characters and in a
world where everything's a cinematic
universe these days and i've actually
said on many occasions like it doesn't
have to be a cinematic universe
that being said i think mortal kombat
does lend itself to being a cinematic
universe they probably should have done
that you know you could have had the
scorpion sub-zero story and that could
have led into
seeing a little bit of the cyber
initiative and then sonia jackson kano
maybe the cyber initiative can tie into
jax getting
his arms kano getting his eye we
actually kind of saw that
uh kano getting his eye and it being
tied to the cyber initiative
in mortal kombat legacy i thought that
was kind of cool so you can have the
side stories and the avengers movie can
be the mortal kombat tournament
regardless we do
get some solid backstory on scorpion
spear
started out as a gardening tool he
turned it into his scorpion spear that's
it's probably the best backstory in the
movie i mean the spear starting out as
scorpion's murdered wife's gardening
tools
better than a skexie had popping out of
his palm in the original movie mortal
kombat fan all my life or at least
as long as mortal kombats have been
around to be mortal kombat and i could
be a fan of it
i still don't know why scorpion spear in
the original movie
is one missing link away from being a
crossover a ridley from metroid
coming out of scorpion's hand molina
nothing about the flesh pits cabal
a reference of him working with kano but
still don't know much about him
riko growling monster even shang tsung i
take for granted the fact that
i like mortal kombat so i know who these
characters are but anyone watching this
would be like
the [ __ ] is this guy who appears in
puffs of smoke to talk some [ __ ] but we
gotta give that spear the backstory
but i liked it however in a world of
them cutting out
lore from the video games i like the
fact that they retconned the retcon see
story was
back in the day in the original mortal
kombat and scorpion that was just it was
the feud between them and their clans
sub-zero kills scorpion
scorpion kills sub-zero sub-zero's
brother then becomes the new sub-zero
it's a pretty pure thing from mortal
kombat 4 it was changed was like no no
it was quan
chi and he basically framed sub-zero and
he just manipulated the whole thing
and original sub-zero didn't actually do
that i guess sub-zero killed scorpion
but not everyone else i always thought
that was stupid i thought it was dumb so
i'm glad
it's not quan chi in this movie just
kept it pure scorpion sub-zero
much better then we get to cole who
should have been liu kang
who are we kidding i mean you have to
change something like it's not like liu
kang
should be the offspring of scorpion's
bloodline that that doesn't make sense
but you just kind of
don't have that to be like no the
scorpion sub-zero thing
that's another thing i'm saying liu kang
should have been coal
just without that element you know
granted you're then dealing with this
very americanized luke hang coming into
the tournament
so you basically have liu kang from the
first movie i'm just saying it's
it makes more sense and that's one of
the things the original movie did better
you know you have liu kang
and this team that's coming into this
whole like oh this mortal kombat
mythology but you have luke kang who
grew up on the stories he didn't really
believe him he was like maybe the
legends were true
he's kind of the ambassador between the
two worlds he's like oh yeah i get what
you're spinning raiden yeah guys this is
kind of what it is which however you
want to see it however you want to slice
it is better than
sonya and jack's being the believers you
know cole's like what's this and sonja's
like there's a tournament and an out
world and a possible invasion we need to
stop it i'm like
so you guys just kind of buy this i
didn't get that i didn't get why
sonya and jax they should be the
skeptics you know they're the military
folks like now we're just kind of going
after kano
and then we're wrapped up in this
tournament oopsy daisy that said i did
like sonya and jax in this movie for
what they
were but i i i don't buy the fact that
they'd be buying any of it they should
have been skeptics
to the end you know until they start
seeing souls get sucked and
you know so maybe you can have sub-zero
do a demonstration
re-shatter somebody in front of people
like the original movie i keep
boomeranging back to the original movie
but i feel like the original movie
gets some [ __ ] it's like yeah well it's
not perfect but no it's not but it does
maintain the spirit of the lore and
that's what i like about it i feel like
there's always give and take you know
the original movie got some things right
over this one
this movie actually got some other
things right over the old movie you look
at the original movie scorpion and
sub-zero they were just
husks there to do shang tsung's bidding
that's pretty stupid this new movie did
scorpion and sub-zero a lot better
granted scorpion i wish he was in it
more but the story was
better and it was more accurate to the
games but the new movie
did goro pretty stupid i mean if you
look at it garo is just kind of a
henchman
who goes to cole's house and tries to
kill him and that's it and then cole
kills him
that's what goro is here for but you
don't have this sense of dread where
it's like dude no one should go up
against
goro this is some pretty big bad [ __ ]
and maybe they used garo
sparingly because they didn't have the
budget to be like we can't have big cgi
garo
all the time we just don't have the
money but i feel like the original movie
didn't have the money and they were like
what to do
hmm let's just have a montage of dudes
kissing gravel
that'll get the point across and it did
so original movie goro much more
menacing
grenady went down with a punch to the
balls
like i said give and take but i suppose
goro was there for coal to
you know find his inner power also dumb
i mean the tattoo thing was
stupid too it's like the tattoo thing is
tied with people
learning their inner power first of all
the tattoo thing reminds me of those
tattoos from annihilation that
fly off enemies and people when they die
i was like oh it's a gateway it's hell
they can cry you don't need that
and i felt like you don't need that in
annihilation and you don't need the
tattoos in here
you don't need people who are oh they're
called they're called to fight in mortal
kombat how about you just have people
come together and they fight for mortal
kombat because they're the ones stepping
up to do it then you have our team sonia
liu kang jax
johnny cage and they do it not because
they have tattoos or they have some
inner power
but because like they've accidentally
stumbled into it's like
all right well like i guess we'll do
this thing now that i know
if we don't no one else will we are the
misfit standing between
our world and annihilation not the movie
the act but no it's like they had to
have the characters in this movie have
these tattoos
which first of all liu kang has a story
about how he killed some scumbag
and then he got his mark so now he gets
to fight mortal kombat i was like
did fate or the elder gods or something
choose some [ __ ]
to represent earth and mortal kombat
that's pretty flawed i guess that person
was there for liu kang to find his inner
power but still flawed long story short
it's like it all
existed to explain how these characters
from this fighting game can do these
extraordinary things
you don't need that for liu kang and
kung lao first of all because kung lao
is to throw his hat which pretty much
acts like
captain america's shield but with a
razor around it captain america's shield
doesn't obey
the laws of physics he didn't have some
inner light
tattoo superpower they even make a joke
about it in the movies about how it
doesn't obey the laws of physics
so just have kung lao throw his hat
people will be like that doesn't well we
roll with it with captain america it's
fine
and that's as much as people would ever
think about it you don't need to explain
it also luke hang
yeah maybe he can shoot fireballs
because he's been hanging out with a god
named raiden maybe raiden taught him a
few things maybe he gave him some powers
he was like i think you're the chosen
one i'll give you the power to shoot
fireballs
not thunder i'm a god though so i guess
i could do that
whatever it's better than a tattoo and
some weird inner power that doesn't
really make that much sense for some
characters i don't need them to throw
fireballs like if liu kang never threw a
fireball i'd be fine with it i
definitely would have been fine with
sonia never shooting pink rings i don't
need to know how she got pink rings
i don't need her to ever throw pink
rings in a mortal kombat movie
she just needs a glock and that inner
light power thing isn't always with
magic abilities that you get
sometimes it what augments and enhances
tech because jax's little little robot
arms became like big jacks arms and i
was like oh
so it works for robot things too i don't
know in a world where i'm sure
the linguist cyber initiative was
already underway
i'm sure the tech existed to give jax
good arms
so he could have gotten better arms and
it didn't have to be a superpower thing
i mean in raiden's little temple in the
desert they somehow had the tech to give
him
robotic arms at all i feel like those
would probably be the low tier robot
arms i'm sure
much better robot arms exist out there
or have him lose his arms in this movie
and then in the next movie comes back
with robot arms jax does the whole hand
clap fatality thing
which i like seeing the fatality but
they were fighting on a precipice it
looked like the pit
and jax did a normal fatality dude if
you're fighting on the pit
you do the pit fatality you're doing
normal fatality on a pit
that's just against etiquette kano gets
a laser eye
in this movie because that's his inner
power though it should have been a
cybernetic eye
and again it's like they were like but
we don't have the budget to have
cybernetic eyes and we're just gonna
make it a superpower and now kano's dead
but he does get stabbed in the eye by
like by a garden gnome or something and
he gets stabbed in the eye
and i i assume when shang tsung said
death is just another
gateway or doorway or something like
that i assume the characters that died
in this movie
like molina kano probably not sexy ass
natara i feel like she's dead riko no
one cares but i feel like some might
come back and kano might come back with
his
cyber eye so there's that but i feel
like kano could have just been kano
without a cyber eye that doesn't shoot
lasers and then when he comes back with
a cyber eye
then he shoots lasers you don't need to
make the lasers his inner light
or whatever and if that is budget and i
assume some of this
does come down to budget like oh we
don't have the budget to show kano's
cyber eye we don't have the budget to
show goro that much
and outworld like you know like we don't
have the budget to show a lot of
outworld outworld was kind of this
gray land where it was just like some
people with rubs were just walking
around looking this place [ __ ] sucked
but like that's all it is you know shang
tsung is in his little
generic throne it's like if you don't
have the budget to show out world then
don't show out world maybe reference
outworld show a peek of outworld
but you don't have to be in out world if
you can't
make it look good give fans something to
look forward to in the next movie maybe
the next movie like oh we're going to
out world and this is like one of the
big gripes is the fact that johnny cage
isn't in this movie but it does take
place before
the mortal kombat tournament this isn't
mortal kombat yet
it's the setup story the mortal kombat
tournament that we've heard about
is yet to happen and we see that with
the fact that cole's like we gotta go
get
johnny cage and for the next movie so
anyhow they're bringing johnny cage in
for the next movie and i maintain i'm
interested to see the next movie because
the next movie gets to what i
like about mortal kombat give us more
scorpion don't just
book end the movie with scorpion at the
beginning scorpion at the end and that's
that though i
thought those scorpion sub-zero fights
when scorpion was alive
when he was when he was hanzo asashi and
when he was scorpion i thought both
those fights were great i want to see
more from this world i just hope they
get a better team i hope they get better
riders to execute it let's just
act like the whole tattoos and super
power
inner light you don't need any of that i
see the potential so i heard they're
down for three movies and i want to see
those three movies i just hope they
polish it up a little
bit i will say this as much as i dug the
scorpion sub-zero fighting
and all the effects that went with it
that i've wanted to see with a scorpion
sub-zero fight for quite some time but
i'll say that there's no
fight in this new mortal kombat that's
as
intense as the liu king reptile fight
from the original
or as clean as the johnny cage scorpion
fight from the original those fights are
highlights of the old movies i thought
they were great so that's it that's my
spoiler talk otherwise known as gripes i
had
that i couldn't talk about in my
spoiler-free review but it does give you
a better understanding
of why it's good time if you're drunk
all right so the new mortal kombat old
mortal kombat mortal kombat annihilation
mortal kombat conquest have you seen
them all what do you think of them and
here it is are you team scorpion are you
team sub-zero in terms of lore fighting
style
there can be only one i was always
scorpion my brother was sub-zero and
that's just
because we're brothers that's how it
goes down whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you